there's a million [ __ ] women in the
world uh yeah the door was
a joke what are you doing in my house
what is john hamm doing in my house he's
starring in a movie and he's kind of
you know shadowing these characters
based on me so the character is a
disgusting pervert
that's good
hey i know that tush anywhere wanda oh
you know who i am
okay i thought i had to turn around show
you my big ass you completely
misinterpreted that hey big ass
i didn't say big ass just saying hello i
was just trying is that how you say
hello
uh well hey what is that that [ __ ] all
over you what you been doing scrounging
around looking for asses
all on the bleachers and say oh where's
the ass
hey what's up what's that is that
jennifer anderson hey you guys made it
yeah
come on in hey sorry go ahead there's
sushi on its way all right
all right good deal nobody um
i'll see you at the meeting tomorrow
yeah get some sleep dude
seriously you look a little
[Music]
excuse me hey can i ask you a favor
would you please take our photograph
so just just do it you would definitely
i got it up here just take it
horizontally don't do this okay
you are constantly undermining every
decision i've made on this trip why
don't you guys work this out okay
seriously oh so no photo yeah i'm out
[Music]
we're seeing you the show oh you're in
the show tomorrow night
great oh i can't wait because you
will fail
how did you know that he could ruin the
show he's got this gift
everything he touches he dooms watch
this
[ __ ] ow i'm
so sorry is that supposed to help sorry
oh thanks oh jesus
christ what the hell
would you shake that up on purpose
parkinson's
[Music]
we got a mobile plan i did shakespeare i
can handle this is there a problem
yeah there's a problem you vandalized my
car
a gust of wind came it blew a rake
off of the um the roof of the house
i was handling it anyway that's how your
car
was damaged all right you're coming with
me
it landed on your vehicle great great
performance
i'm gonna break your [ __ ] teeth your
glasses or something if i don't [ __ ] you
up don't look right
what's going on all day well i remember
mug somebody you know what
this pasty ass [ __ ] got you into
it have him get your ass out of it
i'm 90 to blame for everything 90 i
think 100
100 to blame well i'm taking the lion's
share
no take more than the lions here take
the whole share i'll give you a piece
that's terrific oh i'm so sorry again
for the delay i
have diarrhea i'm gonna come right back
in a little bit and check on you okay
the idea of a spy store such a brilliant
idea i'm gonna open a spiked deli
what's left for me in hollywood win some
award or something you know anytime i
see a customer walk in here that used to
go to ervs
it's like my own tiny little human oscar
walking in here
come and join me settle up yeah yeah
okay just
grab on here yeah grab on here let's see
how we do it yeah
oh this one feels good yeah this is
empowering yeah
just this body position makes me feel
strong i'm tired
did you consult women on this no they'll
love this though
oh yeah what i find interesting in fact
fascinating
is that you would go back to a
restaurant where you and i had a meal
for the sheer purpose of harassing a
waiter we split a check
and and he doesn't want to coordinate
the tip why should i why should i do the
coordination you got with a friend you
dipped in concert
why are we in concert there's no concert
no two different people
two different tips the tip is a solo
larry thank you very much
listen i had a great time i got that no
it's okay it's fantastic
seriously i got that come on you can't
just grab the check if someone has the
check larry that is absolutely rude
i asked you to launch it this is my
pleasure it's not that's my place
give me the checklist give me this doll
hey what's the problem she's a
professional crier
and she can't wait into getting that
store
that's it that's it i can't even that's
it i can't take this anymore
you're such a baby you're uh you're a
grown man baby
can i say and we ordered this kind of
for the table and i feel like you've
gone way over your appetizer allotment
at this point
my allotment well there's three of us we
each get a third
who makes up that [ __ ] rule it's an
unwritten rule
oh my god there's two larry davids
holy [ __ ] pretty good pretty
pretty good
[Music]
you